oh my god that is crazy oh my god my god
hey forgot to tell you congratulations
I'm getting a new job oh thanks man
appreciate ya and thank you for inviting
me over here to the game today oh no
probably appreciate it you're my best
friend
Wow thanks man hey you know what you're
my best friend too cool yeah yeah wrote
a song about it not gonna sing it or
anything cuz that would be gay be gay
alright I'll give it a shot
while you're my best friend together we
can change the world we've been together
through thick and thin playing ball and
talking to girls while he I'm so proud
of you you know you're taking all the my
advice
wait stop stop stop stop what advice oh
um
it's just a song dude I mean like can I
finish and then we can okay you've done
everything I've asked of you when you
never ever question twice talk about
thank you for doing what I told you to
your achievements are also mine my
Padawan you make your sensei proud
living your life living your life living
your life to my G's I I was the weirdest
song I've ever heard my life you ever
listen to your older they never forget
the words I say I don't like your song
you wanna bounce to my creation why no
no I have shown you the wigs
guys curves to the plains of the caribou
sir I have done no liking him the rest
is up to my wolf covers all grown up
you